well we have alireza farouja here with
us the first result of the round with a
draw against fabiano carana alareza
welcome to the show just come from
blasting away your opponents at the same
level as raptor and blitz take us
through some of the key moments of this
game
yeah of course um the first game of the
classical is not easy to switch from
rapid and blitz so i wanted to play
something solid so yeah this queen b3 i
was thinking about it to
make things a bit not less forcing so
so this was uh preparation
and no i just played it over the board
yeah but
i think fight is a bit worse but um
it looks like a playable position so
right so take us through some of the
complications here at after the move d5
fabiano offers you a pawn what went
through your mind yeah so i was
calculating many things um
maybe i should have castled here but
yeah also taking the pawn looks literal
but this knight before d5 looked nice to
force things
forcing things so
maybe after night before i had better
move than queen d1 actually the engine
stock queen d1 was the correct move the
only other better option was to castle
do you consider doing that here yeah you
considered but then yeah giving up the
pawn then it's not so great yeah
absolutely now after the move knight g4
knight bishop takes you found this move
king d2 how did you feel was the
evaluation of this position it's around
it called he felt that he's much worse
for some reason which was weird he told
you this after the game he thought no he
didn't say he's much worse but he said
he was under a lot of pressure but i
think black is here who is maybe playing
for advantage well the king's on d2
after all right yes so but he was
thinking a lot he was burning lots of
time so
yeah then he played this
i think he played correct kind of he did
he just didn't like the move rook fba
precisely because of what happened in
the game and you played this excellent
move f takes e3 f takes e4 and here
we're all wondering
why did you take the bishop on f6 i am
yeah i felt that this if i keep the
knights versus bishop i don't have much
chances and i miss evaluated that the
rookie game is just raw
so
but i don't think it's much anyway after
takes takes p3 bishop e5 so you consider
that both variations were about equality
right yeah i didn't see big reason that
i'm better there because
i have a nice knight but he has also a
nice bishop on e5s a nice bishop yeah
we're definitely going to be hearing
about from vladimir kramnik about this
game well alaresa thanks for joining us
we do have another interview coming up
but good luck in the rest of your games
thank you
thank you
very much indeed for